and uh there can be a better start than
like
thanks uh yeah because it's early in the
morning on Valentine's Day some of us
might be sleepy or distracted so I
thought I'd talk about some
not too terribly technical things some
fun intriguing things
this talk is going to raise
um more questions than it answers uh so
that's why I got this mysterious title
um this is Joint work with nikhil Vias
in itcs 2023 it's actually only one half
of the paper but it's the good half so
yeah I mean and oh and don't be alarmed
uh this will be the only slide using
this Broadway font okay
your eyes will be at ease good
all right so uh I'll start with a
question that uh many of us love which
functions have high stereo complexity
and about the first thing you learn
about so your complexity is that nearly
all functions have high survey
complexity so most functions require
huge circuits and I think Rahul santanam
uh mentioned this yesterday so with high
probability randomly chosen function
doesn't have circuit Society significant
lesson to the N over n and the lupinov
showed every function has a size Circuit
of size about to the N over n and this
still does omitting like a a one plus
level of one multiplicative Factor so
just like a low order term right
right and then pictures
um you're tossing a bunch of coins you
have some really long string okay that's
a random bit string okay it's washed out
okay it's a white box I guess okay
and it does not have a small circuit so
a simple counting argument
right and the big question uh that we
like to think about is which natural
functions exert this exponential
Behavior which you know functions which
don't take too much touring uh resources
like time or space exhibit this kind of
exponential Behavior right so this is a
type of question we're going to be
looking at
um so just to rephrase
we're going to ask what is the smallest
complexity class containing a function
of Maximum certain complexity okay just
to get started again smallest I put in
quotes because it could be some
incomparable classes that Each of which
contain a hard function
so one of the smallest known classes I
think this probably is the smallest
According to some Metric is uh two to
the order in time with a sigma 2p Oracle
and this was known since the 1970s okay
I'm the first talk so I'm going to
explain uh you know or recall what Sigma
2p is in a moment so there's a function
in this e to the sigma 2p that requires
maximum circumplexity
okay recall Sigma 2p is MP to the MP so
the predicate is you know there exists a
poly length y for all Pi length Z some
verifier accepts on both of those all
right
you know some somewhere in the Panama
hierarchy not too high a canonical
problem in Sigma 2p is for example
circuit minimization I give you a
Boolean circuit and I want to know is
there a circuit smaller than the one
given that competes the same function
um this is another problem that we
believe to be hard but we don't actually
know if it's a sigma 2p hard so it's
like you know for among the other meta
complexity problems it's like one level
up in the polynomial hierarchy
so so that's uh the sort of smallest
known class let me just give a just a
high level sketch of how that works
so on an input of LinkedIn first we're
going to compute what is the maximum
circuit complexity as star of a function
on N inputs all right
so we start with 2 to the N which we
know is too large we're going to
decrease it so while for every function
it has a circuit of size at most s okay
you can formulate this as a pi 2 p query
so you can ask Sigma 2p so it's like for
all functions does there exist a circuit
such that the circuit computes the
function okay but remember these are to
the end linked queries so evaluation on
all possible inputs is is polynomial for
us so it's a 2 to the order and length
query to a sigma 2p order we ask this
and while that's true we decrement s
okay
all right when this fails to work there
is some function that doesn't have
circuits of size in most s so then the
maxer complexity is is one more okay
it's like the the last one for which you
actually had a circuit of size in most s
all right so once you've got the maximum
circuit complexity which we actually
don't know how to compute we know it's
on the order to the integral but we
don't know exactly what it is this uh
procedure computes it then we use some
search decision reduction on the sigma
2p Oracle kind of filling in bits uh to
figure out what is the graphically first
truth table that has circuits of size uh
uh s star and and the less
all right so that's just a high level uh
idea of how you
do that I'm I mean just to get you
started this is not like the point of
the talk is just to let you you know
kind of ground you in like what is known
so okay all right
it's an old old theorem okay so once
I've done all that I output the X bit of
the truth table I've got because I'm
trying to compute it on X right
all right good
are we awake yet are we
okay
good good all right so so this lower
bound relative Rises and that'll be
important for us so let a be some
arbitrary Oracle so arbitrary decision
problem we can plug in
okay we have Sigma 2p with an oracle a
where we just plug in the Oracle into
the verifier
and we say there's a function in e to
the sigma 2 to the a that requires
maximum a Oracle circuit complexity okay
what is an aortical circuit you get n or
not the ands and ORS at nn2 but you also
get uh an a like gates for a and you
compute a on any number of inputs you
want well up to whatever the maximum
circuit complexity let's go to your
counting in terms of the wires when you
count with unbounded fan and Gates the
compute a but so the previous argument
didn't really like think about circuits
uh you could you could just if you had a
verifier that was checking aortical
circuits it could do a Oracle circuit
evaluation everything would just go
through okay like many other results in
complexity Theory this one also relative
lies all right
good
uh we'll get to the missing string don't
worry it's coming okay so so as a
corollary this is just some nice little
corollary uh if P equals MP then there's
a function in E that requires maximum
circuit complexity and that's just you
know
uh plugging in P equals NP many times
okay and this also relativizes okay
um so right this gives us an oracle
relative to which uh e has maximum
circuit complexity by plugging in
whatever in Oracle so that P equals NP
so just as inside one could conclude PD
from MP if one could show every function
in E has cir complexity at most uh one
minus the maximum
um this is something that I learned from
I guess Charlie Rockoff and this was his
approach to proving Peter from MP okay
um I don't I guess he didn't succeed
anyway so yeah
well he didn't tell us oh he just
this is possible I suppose definitely
true obvious yeah he would did you yeah
Valentina did you know I thought yeah
yeah because yeah he was missing
it yeah yeah so you know this is one way
to possibly if you don't believe in
circular balancing okay
what does it mean by every function in e
what's that what do you mean by every
function
yeah I mean what do I mean by that I
mean like every like decision problem
s
you could show that the empty set to the
Circuit complexity of most yes at most
yes or at most at most yes yes it's very
easy to show
yeah it's good well we're awake just
um just uh for this statement is enough
to show up for something complete
problem or just the reduction kind of
missiles you know yeah I mean you like
you gotta apply the thing to multiple
things so yeah I mean I had to check out
yeah
because uh the e-complete problem like
like you really care about linear
factors now
so yeah I mean but if you want to like
yeah if you wanted to if you could show
like too little of in for any complete
problem you're good
right right so yeah you actually care
about like like all the factors because
like it's like age of n there's like no
room
hey whatever but uh okay this is again
this is just a warm-up it gets you uh
you know so we'll all be Awakening times
great
um so like if we could show that either
MP you know which is smaller supposedly
uh needs exponential size circuits for
example then by prg constructions uh
that's let's say it holds almost
everywhere we would have for example bbp
contained in P to MP well that's a major
open problem to improve the containment
of BBB in say Sigma 2 or MH of P to the
MP
um okay but this is sort of you know
what we're up against to try like to try
to show a smaller function needs uh
exponential sorry complexity
but there doesn't seem to be any real
barrier to improving this e to the sigma
2p to Sigma to e okay so just the
exponential time version right so this
is uh in time to the order n with an MP
Oracle so it could be a SAT Oracle this
is the exponential time and log of Sigma
2p so right it's not a deterministic
class where you get to call in Oracle
you just have Sigma 2 e yes so
just to be picky yes
um
is is Sigma 2E really the same as end
time to the MD because
because that seems like it would
um
I don't see why not but how long would
the Oracle okay I'll think about it yeah
I mean you get to ask through the order
of family queries to an MP Oracle but
Paul to the end is to the order in
is not to the end of the okay
if that's what you're worried about
that's all I'm worried about yeah yeah
okay yeah polynomial to the end let's do
the order at so we're actually all right
okay
I had to verify this for myself yeah you
know that's true
we're awake good good right so the point
is when consequence of that would be you
know we could be say sing with 2p but we
already know that so it's not so there's
really any real barrier to improving
this and let me elaborate on uh the
doesn't seem to be any real barrier
parts
so I'll rephrase it again
um the sigma 2E contain a function
requiring exponential size circuits all
right right so so this seemingly smaller
but still exponential still difficult
complexity class doesn't need
exponential size circuits all right
so it's been known since Canon that it
requires sub half exponential circuits
whatever that means it's early into the
poly login that requesting the following
inside circuits all right so it's been
known for a really long time but the
interesting thing is we don't even know
if there's an oracle
uh such that Sigma 2E has small circuits
like selectional side circuits so we
can't even design our Oracle for which
that is true
as far as We Know okay now we know those
are Oracle relative which has
exponential side circuits that's the
Oracle of which P equals NP that I just
mentioned a moment ago we don't know if
there's an oracle under which this thing
has small circuits so
uh so this is opened
okay is is there such an oracle
well what's the consequence of that well
it's possible that there's a
relativeizing proof of proof using
totally standard techniques maybe
similar to the one for each of the sigma
2p that this Sigma 2E needs exponential
size circuits want to just use a
standard Black Box techniques it's
totally possible in the real
impossibility all right now
um what does this have to do with
Mysteries well we'll give a new way of
thinking about questions like these so
not only this question but sort of any
question involving relativization and
exponential size circuits can be
rephrased in terms of a very simple
problem the third complexity of a very
simple problem
right
so this is the missing string problem
and it's a really simple problem okay
given a list of M strings of length n
where m is less than
to the N uh oh
to the end find a string on the list
okay it's a total function problem I
mean as long as I don't include it all
the strings there is some string on the
list I want you to find one that's it
all right
so if the list what does that have to do
with hardness and well the list is truth
tables of all the easy functions we're
asking you to find a hard function okay
so yeah so it's like here's all the
things that are easy find me something
that's not there
that's that's the problem
okay so it can be viewed uh as an
exponential size version of another
problem which is seen a lot of attention
recently and in fact you'll see some
attention paid to it later today I guess
Hamlin is giving a talk on on this
problem it's called range avoidance so
given a Boolean circuit from Little in
bits to Capital in bits where capital in
this thing is
no Catalan is greater than in
final string uh in the output that's not
in the range okay
all right so you've got like more
possible outputs than you do inputs so
there's got to be something not in the
range there's only two to the N inputs
in the range there's two of the M
possible outputs all right
so random string works with probability
these to have is handling will probably
tell you but to check that the given y
actually works require some call to set
you have to check as far as you know
there is no input that will actually
output this y
in fact circuit set right
right so deterministic algorithms for
this range avoidance problem naturally
can be used to construct explicit
functions that don't have small circuits
so imagine that c is something that
takes descriptions of small objects like
circuits or whatever and prints truth
tables Okay maps and other truth tables
um right so then finding something not
in the range is exactly finding a hard
function
okay we're going to look at this even
like much much simpler problem missing
string because once you throw circuits
in there you know things become
difficult so I want to keep it easy so
let's just look at missing string
so variance of this problem
apparently pop
in coding interviews I don't know I've
never had to do one of these thank God
but there are apparently phrases like
missing integer so like that but so
let's see one way to solve this thing uh
efficiently
um so there's like for example an hotel
to M time algorithm for missing string
um
and let's just say it's a random access
model we're not going to care too much
about that and because I guess learning
is a topic of this Workshop it's a
having algorithm okay that's what I'm
going to call it a happy having
algorithm so our missing string will be
some x with bits X1 through xn so we
probe the first bit of every string and
we set you know the first bit of our bad
string to be the minority bids of those
okay then we probe the second bits of
all those strings that agree in that
Minority bit
and we said our next bit to be the
minority bit of those
okay we prove the third bit of all the
strings that agree in those first two
bits is that the minority bit of those
so we're kind of like you know
unlearning we're trying to like not you
know get something not on the list okay
um after
long and rounds of this uh no strings
are left okay and then we if we didn't
actually you know cover all the bits of
uh X we just fill in the remaining ones
with zeros
okay
well yeah it should be capital M yeah it
isn't even a little M on the slide other
than that one so it's capitalism yeah
yeah so this gives you like the lower
Bound in X position sharp B to the end b
or something like that
you know like majority sets Oracle
that's yeah yeah I think even like the
class where you can kind of set to like
an additive
yeah
yeah I mean you could do approximate
counting but that takes more words so um
yeah I mean and this is still a linear
time algorithm or whatever closely
linear so yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you
could imagine doing approximate counting
like you only get approximate minority
and then you can get away with
oh I mean yeah yeah there's definitely
some pictures yeah yeah it's me but you
end up getting something like
each of the promise a.m but you have to
be careful about like using it a little
without it okay for reasons I definitely
don't want to talk about uh
so so how many probes does this thing
use into the string so remember it's
it's m times n Bits total right uh so it
takes M probes to get the first bit M
over two and most of them over two to
get the second and over four the total
number of probes is actually order M
almost like 2m
okay and uh there's in fact a paper
called diagonalization games that appear
on archive in early January that uh I
guess Nails uh what that what that uh
inside the Big O okay
good missing string very simple problem
so what are we going to do we're going
to show a strong equivalence between
questions like is there an oracle a so
that Sigma 2 with this a Oracle has a
work Circuit of too little of in size
and the complexity of finding a missing
string okay there's going to be like a
strong equivalence between like
complexity class essential complexity
class has a Oracle circuits that are
small and uh Missing string uh does not
have uh circuits of a particular type
like low depth circuits a particular
type okay so efficient circuits for
missing string actually correspond to
efficient circuits of constructions of
hard functions so here if you design a
good algorithm for missing string you
are actually proving a better lower
bound you're improving the complexity of
constructing a hard function
okay so this is there this is directly
like algorithms implying lower bounds
okay and then another guys
so here's an example serum I'll give you
a few of these before I State the
the generic result
so for every Oracle a uh Sigma 2E with a
requires two Epsilon n size a Oracle cir
complexity almost everywhere if and only
if there are uniform depth 3 ac0
circuits for missing string of two to
the poly Kaplan size and polycaplan
bottom thinning on all lists of length M
about two to the end of the Epsilon okay
by uniform I mean
uh like poly log uh uniform in the input
okay
all right
so there's an equivalence here so the
problem that we're asking about oracles
boils down to whether missing string has
such circuits or not
um if you could prove you know even say
a non-uniform that free lower music
string it would you know it would uh
imply there must exist such an oracle
I mean there's a sense in which
um oracles are like all the possible
inputs that can come into missing string
and if you can find like bad inputs that
make missing string require High
circumflexity then you're actually
finding Oracles in which uh this thing
has small sorry place
yeah it's it's a it's pretty weird uh
but it's yeah so it's an algorithmic
equivalence between uh sort of ac0
algorithms and improving uh
the hard function improving the
complexity of the heart function here
so I drew some picture here yeah so so
we got the depth three circuits let's
say it's got ores it could have ands to
the top then ands These have two the
polycaplin fan in and at the bottom
there's a small finite and we we have n
times M bits there's M strings of
LinkedIn we've got to Output a missing
string right so this thing's got to
Output M bits we got sort of you can
think of having a separate circuit for
each of the possible output bits
now note that since we set M to be about
two to the end of the Epsilon we're
asking for a circuit this
quasi-polynomial in the input size right
that means that this is two to the end
of the Epsilon we're asking this to the
poly uh in so it's like so it's quasi
quasi polynomial in the nipple link so
this is kind of like uh
um
the the model in which yeah we want to
we want to understand whether this thing
can compute a missing string or not such
a simple problem I feel like we should
be able to figure it out unfortunately
we haven't yet so that's what happened
so the thing I want to mention here is
that depth 3 is crucial so often when
you think about AC zero lower bounds
like there's always some sort of sized
up Trail okay almost always some sort of
size depth trade-off right like you can
if you buy this much more depth you can
decrease the size by this much here
there is nothing of the source there's
ABS there's nothing like that okay so
for example we can plug in
non-deterministic exponential times
equivalence
okay we'll get depth two ac0 circuits
but the thing is there's a lot of work
in relative eye circumplexity and so
actually we know that this is false that
we know that there are oracles around
which any actually has linear circuits
okay so this automatically translates to
a lower bound there's no depth two
circuits
okay
so so yeah you can use like various uh
relative eyes oracles showing that this
surprisingly large class has small
circuits to prove various lower bounds
of missing yes so I think our best lower
bounds for depth three AC zero circuits
for functions in P are like two to the
square root of that yeah how does that
translate here would you have to beat
that no no that would be enough but the
problem is it like I don't see how it
fits in the missing string so we just
need to quasi polynomial or about
actually
yeah yeah so the input length is this
right this is the input length and we
want through the poly end so that's
actually just causing polynomial in the
input length
yeah
so you said that the Wilson just opened
like the depth to lower bounds can you
put that to lower Bound for this in this
case yeah yeah so you can actually look
at his it has proof and just extracts
exactly directly at the lower belly yeah
yeah it's just sort of like yeah you
just sort of follow like what he's doing
against
yeah yeah it's the lower bound that you
get a uniform one or a
it's even non-uniform it's even
non-uniform yeah yeah
yeah
yes uh when you say when you're when
you're providing the input different you
say on all lists of like should I think
of it as having two to the N inputs but
two to the end of the Epsilon or one you
know what I mean to the Epsilon r one no
no so Epsilon is a fixed constant it's
here it's not understanding how basic
string gets provided as input to the
Circuit so I have like a bit for every
possible string I have n Bits for every
possible string the strings
so it's like the input is a link capital
N times I see and you have like M yeah
yeah that's why I put the whatever this
approximately yes yeah
yeah I mean it's important
um for the equivalence but like if you
prove right you're not uniform lower
bound it implies a uniform over balance
so like One Direction it's fine with not
uniformly
okay but yeah yeah yeah I don't I don't
even know they're not uniform yes so
question uh so you said that we have
these sub half exponential though so do
those translate to some sort of circuit
constructions or circuit logos oh
uh they should they should I mean if a
relative lies and they do yeah so they
yeah they definitely do I mean uh
that's that's also true so it would only
like give you something that works
infinitely often like it would give you
ac0 circuits but but you need to use the
input online
um
I think you could write down like an
explicit a function that would require
it but you don't know which input links
it would work on
yes because because you know that
sorry the function will involves two
different input and you can only go into
it either so I mean there I know that
for Sigma 2p there are explicit
functions that need
uh let's say into the case size circus I
thought you could probably just lift one
of those
like there are ways of dealing with this
simply So like
um and your functions
have a paper where they have like
explicit function that's you know so you
don't have to worry about two different
input lengths
okay so that three is crucial right so
what do you believe in circuit lower
bounds you believe like any requires
electrical side circuits then that means
that there actually are a depth two
circuits for succinct instances of
missing string where succinct is the
usual interpretation of there's a small
circuit that will generate the instance
for you
right so so so this is like some weird
way in which
um here's a problem like we know a lower
bound on arbitrary like random instances
say but uh for succinct instances we
believe there actually is a good
algorithm here's a better algorithm so
like as some sort of weirdness you know
we normally think of P equals MP and x
in x equals X as being roughly the same
but this is anyway yes that's the same
for like d randomization yeah yeah you
can think of like the problem of
of finding a one it is done string sure
um
sure it's true this is the same thing
change the size of each time
[Music]
no it doesn't it doesn't change like any
of like the input link parameters just
saying that there's a small circuit that
generates
oh
okay okay
season three set or succinct whatever
graph problem it means that there's a
small circuit that generates the like a
poly size they're gonna generate
exponential size object
promise
um you know so it's like you just want a
depth 2 circuit that is only guaranteed
to succeed on succinct instances yeah
right it doesn't work on all inputs or
it doesn't have to well it won't but it
doesn't because yeah
yeah it said it said it it can be
existing it can be compressive right
yeah yep
good
um okay so another example theorem we
get so if we move up to Sigma 3 number 3
where we know um lower bounds because
Sigma 3 e contains this e to the sigma
2T so we get some equivalents with that
before and that's known to be true
right so that lower bound relative is
the the one that gets maximum
circumplexity and so therefore we know
that that's four circuits exists in fact
okay so we know that that four circuits
exist
um we know that too does not exist we
want to know about depth three okay
that's that's sustainability it's also
plus I mean if you think about the
argument they're basically taking a dead
four circuit yep and yep that's yeah
it's an exercise to construct a dead
four circuit from the organ yeah yeah
you just yeah you're looking for a
lexography first thing if you think
about what happens it turns out to be
debt four yeah you can try to make a
debt free I tried but it's good
because you can try them
um so here's the statement of the
general theorem okay
so I'll just tell you like at a really
high level like what is the general
equivalence so we want to have some
general stable exponential time classes
so let GE be some arbitrary uh decision
problem
and we say that f is in G of e so think
of G as like the or function or the and
function or the majority function if
there's a constant C in a turing machine
running in to the C in time where n is
the length of X and Y is the exponential
length Witness
so that for all X
f of x is one if and only have this G on
all possible choices for y right Y is of
length 2 to the c n so we're trying all
possible choices of wait I think I threw
an extra two there okay well yeah
there's a it should just be like yeah
that's too many it should just be 2 to
the CN okay anyway the the number of
such strings is that much okay and we're
asking whether that is equal to one so
like for example if uh we compute the
aura function we're just asking if there
exists a witness that makes this machine
except and that'll be the same as in
time to the ordering
Okay and like if we have the and
function there'll be Coen time we'll
take the majority that'll be P time and
and so on
so the generic theorem is just sort of
an informal statement is that for every
Oracle this G uh dot e with a needs
exponential aortical circumflex the if
and only if missing string has circuits
of the following type it's a big big G
of decision trees of polynomial depth or
poly in depth we're in in is uh the
lengths of the string but again like
this is like a poly log because our
input length is roughly 2 to the uh into
the Epsilon this is true for
true it's true for all G's yeah yeah so
this is just generic statement so so the
point is there's lots of other weird
classes like PX where actually there are
small circuits and then you get Oh
missing string doesn't have a majority
of decision trees of this disc so
there's lots of like weird like oracles
that's showing like surprising a Oracle
certain complexity collapses
they give you this thing so so you can
extract a lot of results just from like
known oracles uh a different lower
bounds on missing string from that
all right I just want to state that and
and then um sort of give you an idea
of of how this uh theorem works so let
me just
sketch like how you prove this the
easier case of this equivalence so this
is the case we care about
um so if they're a uniform or an or for
example circuits for missing string to
the poly in size poly and bottom fan in
on all lists of of length
um about two to the into the Epsilon
then we would get the sigma 2E
requires uh through the Epsilon size or
complexity in fact we would get it
um
or oracles uh well at least they're
exist Oracle so so this is the
algorithms imply lower bounds Direction
okay this is the this is sort of the
thing we would like to prove but there
might end up being a depth-free lower
Bound for missing string anyway
like how this goes it's not very hard I
mean but just to sort of lay it out so
you can see it
so our signature function will evaluate
the debt-free circuit for missing strain
so this is a uniform thing so it's it's
poly log so I can uh given a particular
gate like the output gate I can easily
figure out what are the different input
labels of input uh Gates going into that
right so we'll evaluate this missing
string
the list of all true tables of functions
with circuits of size to the Epsilon n
so we're just going to imagine that
that's the input now I just want to
evaluate this uniform circuit okay and
figure out like what is what is the ice
bit of his output for a given I so
that's that's the the thing I want to do
right so so our n is to the N right or
we have these links of true tables to
the end we have
M uh possible circuits
and most due to the order
uh to the Epsilon n times n of these so
on an input X our Sigma to a function
just tries to com output the X output of
the missing string circuit right so it's
a 2 to the N bit output so we can index
it by some X of n Bits
we just existentially guess and then put
wire to the output or gate which is true
and that's coming from some and gate g
we universally trial input wires to the
and Gates coming from that's coming from
some or gate h but that organ H has Low
Bottom fan and remember has like poly in
bottom fan so we can just evaluate all
these literals uh having wires all the
literals that have wires going into that
and except if and only if at least one
of those literals is true right so we
get something that's Sigma 2E
this is just sort of because it has this
like Low Bottom fan and we can we can
spin polycapitalin at the end right
because capital N is to the N so that's
to the order n time
right uh these guesses are linked to the
order in both of these guesses
um because of our our fan is to the poly
in size we're just going to guess one of
them so it's poly and bits to write one
of them down coming in
okay so assuming we can compute local
information on the gates of the circuit
this whole process can be done into the
order in time on Sigma 2 machine
so sort of the algorithms imply lower
balance Direction
all right
now for the other direction
um right we we want to make it so that
like if something requires a Oracle
certain complexity somehow this implies
a lower bound and the thing is like if
you just start thinking about this
problem a Oracle circuits can become
complicated
well it turns out that they don't have
to be complicated so
so
um
oh yeah so there's a normal form so so
the main answer to the question why is
there like a tight connection here is
that there's a certain precise sense in
which real devised circumplexity is
Trivial like it's a trivial notion the
structure of the circuit actually makes
no difference in a in a certain rigorous
sense okay Russell is nodding so I guess
you already know this but you can expose
the structure in the in the Oracle you
can put destruction in the Oracle yeah
that's essentially what this slide says
okay so so like an aortable circuit can
look really complicated like this right
so we say a over circuit is Trivial if
it has the following form okay it's just
a with like a bunch of
bits hard-coded in okay and we count the
size as the number of these wires so we
count we still we're not cheating on
size we say Okay number of extra bits
you got to plug in uh that counts as
your size
all right
so we measure size by number of inputs
and
so the theorem is yeah Suppose there
exists some Oracle a so that's C time to
the a to the order n as a or equal
circuit so size that's a bit and C time
could be D time end time BP time Sigma
two times Sigma three whatever it could
be many many different uh classes here
supposed to Oracle a of the left hand
side form okay then there is the Oracle
B of the right hand side form okay so
there's the Oracle B so that's the same
class really that Oracle B has trivial B
Oracle circuits okay so you don't so you
don't actually have to think about it
with respect to this so this is why like
finding even a single Oracle
um will give you lower bounds on missing
string and a nice way now there's a way
there's a sense in which like all you
got to do is just print out you know
what a does with the with like various
strings hard coded here
um
okay
right so no so with all those generality
we can just work with trivial circuits
when we're considering statements about
whether they exists in Oracle or not
because so it actually is really
simplifies like the whole idea and if
you look at these are all the highest
certain complexity papers there the way
they design the the sort the Oracle
circuits always look like this anyway
so so uh okay I guess that's why so the
idea is really simple give it an oracle
a you said Oracle B to be a Oracle
circuit evaluation
okay so the aortical circuit evaluation
is given the description of a equal
circuit given an input evaluated
evaluate the circuit on input right
okay so then um so then all you do so
you have your B here you take the
description of this you plug it in here
boom
that's it no no so like I said I give
you the input I give you the circuit
tell me the value of the input on the
circuit
that's all that's that's all this is
like okay so as long as C time to the a
to the order n equals c time to B to the
order n we're okay
right so
right so for circuit evaluation and for
these particular classes that's true I
mean it's true in a more General sense
you can see the paper if you want but
that's that's it
yes what'd be a dumb question but why
can't you have the Oracle be
cheat around the circuit size but just
for fixing one particular a Oracle
circuit and saying that the able to
evaluating such a circle
so it's not taking flexibility
yeah I'm not sure I I'm not sure I
understand that question and I'm running
a little short on time so let me let me
just it's a great
um yeah I'm running really short on time
yeah 45 minutes is tough actually how
much time do I have maybe five minutes
maybe five minutes okay all right I'll
deal with that one okay so so yeah 45
minutes is not it's not easy so
so I want to talk briefly about local
algorithms for finding a missing string
um and this is useful for for improving
uh lower bounds and in a sense that
we'll see so it starts with just
Cancer's diagonal argument which says
look if the number of strings at most
the number of bits in the string then we
can find a missing string by just taking
the diagonal
okay so right if if m is at most n then
we can just take the diagonal flip the
bits right and what we can say from this
is like okay for all of the possible uh
output bits of the missing string we can
actually compute that bit by just making
one probe into the input right so it's a
compute the I bit of the missing string
here we just make one bit probe this is
this is actually very convenient and in
fact this is sort of why we'll have time
hierarchy theorems are so so tight
because you're actually just you're
actually just sort of on any particular
input right you think this is like a
truth table your only particular input
you're just uh querying uh one of the
easy functions just calling one of the
easy function flipping the answer
okay
all right so so I will say that means
that there's a one probe algorithm for
missing strain okay so to compute the
ith bit of the missing string you just
need to make one probe in the input
that's it good
all right so then so okay I I have a
parameter one no the natural question is
what happens when I increase this
parameter
okay so under what conditions can we use
only K probes
so like what how how big can the list MB
so that we can get away with K probes
right because we want the list M to be
as big as possible because we want to
like get a missing string out of a lot
of easy functions right imagine the the
list being like functions that have
small circuits as the list gets bigger
and bigger we are finding a harder and
harder function right so we want to make
M as large as possible here
okay so that's just summarizing what I
had before we're going to do with K
probes it's easy to see if m is K times
n there's no K minus one probe algorithm
okay
um the idea is that like the total
number of probes you make is uh is so
small you there's some string you didn't
even probe okay so there's some string
like if you make only K minus one probes
there's some string you didn't probe at
all so like any algorithm no whatever
you report you can have adversarial
input that just plugs in that uh what
you reported as uh you know one of the
strings you didn't probe so okay that's
that's uh easy so there's a k order K
log K probe algorithm missing string
um maybe I will skip it if you really
want to know uh you can ask me in the
questions
um
just because I don't want to take
too much time
okay so so there is like an order K log
K probe algorithm when the number of
strings is the most K times the number
of bits
the coral area is that you get new time
hierarchy theorems against uh
non-uniform programs okay so here's some
old private hierarchy theorems against
the device so it was known that if you
had like h of n uh growing say faster
than G of n so you could show that h of
n is not time is not in time G of n with
n Bits of advice
and the usual primary theorem kind of
just works there you can you can have in
you can diagonalize against uh programs
that have in bits of advice so for each
input of links in there is a program of
size n you can still diagonalize that
with a uniform function
another sort of theorem is
um if you have arbitrary G and H you can
list all the programs of length G of N
and diagonize against them like this and
you can get some uniform function inside
this and this is how you for example can
construct a function exponential time
that doesn't have
in squared size circuits for example all
right so these are like the old
hierarchies so here are some examples of
new hierarchies that improve uh these
bounds like by two the N factors
um one interesting thing so here so
we're saying time to the CN is not in
time order n with c n plus n Bits of
device the interesting thing about that
is that these are all device
and there's actually an oracle uh such
that if you make the time bound of the
hard function a little bit smaller is
that this no longer holds and in fact uh
you can you can get Oracle circuits that
are of this like really small size okay
so there's a sense in which this is
optimal
all right
okay uh yes Duke is Oracle bad proven
lower bounds from these industries
um
do I get it by proving no I don't but uh
you could do it that way though you can
always I mean they're equivalent
essentially right just basically I buy a
sort of a pro blower balance yeah
against Miss history yeah you could you
could take them I mean basically all
those relative eyes Oracle things you
can always like we haven't found a
single example where it's not easy just
go back and say oh here's a lower ballot
for this weird circuit class uh solving
this extreme yeah which means
[Music]
yeah I guess I mean for certain
parameters right like it's like uh for
missing string instances coming from
this this this and this yeah
yeah
okay so here are the main open problems
that are left those missing string have
small uniform debt three circuits or not
you can't have depth two we don't have
duck four we've got three is a sweet
spot I mean that three there's other
ways in which you can get lower bounds
like Pablo has uh work and the various
works like using a satisfied really
coding Lemma in these top down lower
bounds where you there's different ways
of getting that through lower bounds so
maybe they're for depth three there are
some special techniques you can use to
get lower bounce
um yeah I really don't know what the
answer is so lower bounds upper bounds
fine fine
streets the I actually don't know is
there another problem that has this kind
of form that anyone knows about I don't
know
there's all uh
yeah I mean
I don't know I mean like
examples are welcome I don't know a
problem that has it's weird to say this
like about three okay so the next
question is how many probes are
necessary and sufficient to financing
string when the number of strings that
most K times them right so we get some
triall they answer somewhere between K
and Order K okay uh we don't know
um
and then since we're also this Workshop
also is average case complexity in it I
should talk about average case
complexity in the class minus something
minutes I have so so finding an average
case star function corresponds to
finding uh some kind of remote point so
a string far and Hemi distance from all
the ones on the list right so can we
rule out that three circuits for this
harder problem so I think it's an
interesting question all right
that's all thank you
good question
so a question if you can hear me
um okay for this last bullet do you have
an equivalence like before that if you
can solve a remote point then you have
average question function is this a
formal equivalence oh
um like an average case thing I mean as
far as I can tell
um there should be a close I didn't
write it the proof down though so but I
don't I don't really see a reason why
um
so right the equivalence would be
something like
um whether we can
whether we can show that uh Sigma 2E has
like even like it's hard to approximate
with circuits right exactly yeah I I
don't see a reason why the what we did
wouldn't work but
oh I don't know of relative advising
it's a good question he's asking whether
it's relativizing worst case average
case reductions sir
yes another question if you give me
um can you give me like a simple setting
of parameters for this uh problem the
the least problem that I can think about
like it's over like like list of size n
with n Bits uh yeah I mean you can you
can change around the parameters you can
change the variables if you want to but
I mean it's um
I mean you can yeah right like sometimes
it's easier if you change the variables
but uh for me yeah it's it's this so
This many strings
of n Bits And secretly right we think of
n is like capital N is the length of a
truth table can you see this
yes yes yes I can see everybody okay
yeah so but yeah you can you can make it
you can change it around and make it a
function of capitalism if you like uh I
can pick an episode I want so if it
helps yeah yeah yeah so this is going to
translate to to the Epsilon n uh size
lower bounds yeah I'm just thinking
what's like a simple Circle problem uh
for some specific settings or parameters
uh but you can set up zombie a half yeah
square root okay I don't know what else
do okay
I guess let me put it this way the
simplest setting uh for which we we
don't have an answer oh
well I mean for all we know
um Sigma 2 e has an oracle with linear
size circuits so you could you could
make this like
poly log uh you can make this yeah Pi
login if you want Capital One okay
okay so let's take questions
thank you
foreign